once they were not just the centerpiece
of the Trump campaign they were the
first evils out of its Pandora's box the
wall along the Mexican border and the
deportation of around 11 million
undocumented Americans the starting line
of this whole wretched hateful bigoted
nightmare what empowered the alt-right
and in flames and a phobia and imperiled
something that's been fundamental to
this nation since slavery ended the idea
that if you were born here you were an
American the wall still comes up now and
again but what was that other thing oh
yeah the mass deportation how exactly
would that work how exactly would you
take 11 million people and make them you
know leave especially if and I'm going
way out on a limb here they you know
didn't want to leave 11 million people
11 million people is the population of
the entire state of Ohio three and a
half percent of the population of all of
us even now a year and three months into
this triumph of delusion and ego over
reality and stuff like math and science
there is no policy nor guidance about
this to be gleaned from the Trump
website or from the campaign other than
his surrogate chris Christie's
declaration that two to three million
people would be targeted for immediate
deportation and Trump's own claims that
he would deport any undocumented
American accused of a crime not
convicted just accused and of course the
original plan to quote triple the number
of Immigration and Customs Enforcement
agents but Trump's insistence that he
would do it all humanely a wildly
generous estimate is there are 100,000
agents now so we tripled that to 300,000
300,000 people to humanely round up 11
million undocumented Americans that is
37 undocumented Americans per agent if
you triple the number of agents if
somehow the whole process from finding
these people to apprehending them to
giving them whatever is left of due
process by then to maybe an appeal to
transportation to expulsion if that all
takes six months per undocumented
American it currently takes on average
18 months if it's only six months
Trump's deportation force could humanely
get the whole job done in only 19 years
presuming that is that all the
undocumented Americans cooperate and all
their friends cooperate and their
relatives cooperate and their employers
cooperate and ordinary Americans who
think it is the work of the devil to
round up and expel people who risk their
lives to get here and are willing to
live their lives in the shadows to stay
here presuming they also cooperate when
the trucks come for their friends and
their neighbors and it would still take
one agent about 19 years to get his 37
undocumented Americans out of America
now if say each case required the work
of three members of that 300,000 person
Trump deportation force the project
would not be completed until about the
year 2000 and 72 and that still assumes
those who are forced out do not come
back in now no matter what numbers and
dates are actually realistic because
there's another scenario in which
Trump's ethnic cleansing I'm sorry I
meant to say humane deportation in which
the humane deportation could be
concluded by 2027 there's still one
giant humane problem looming in the
background these 11 million people are
not simply going to line up on a given
day and march out of the country you're
gonna have to take these people and
remove them from society go to their
homes and for one of a better word
capture them capture as many people who
now live in the state of Ohio and take
them somewhere else until the process of
expulsion from the country is complete
is Donald Trump thinking of humanely
keeping them in his hotels no there
would have to be humane deportation
centers of some kind
these would in fact be camps of some
kind and the living arrangements would
necessarily be cramped crowded congested
confined what is the word I'm looking
for
concentrated that's it the camps would
be concentrated where people would be
humanely held in you know concentrated
places where the deportee residents were
in a humane state of being concentrated
where these humane camps had the quality
of concentration camps with
concentration and unless you want these
camps with concentration to just
hemorrhage money they're gonna have to
be a lot of camps with concentration all
around the country to make
transportation easier places to round up
and humanely keep the 300,000
undocumented Americans from Dallas alone
or the 400,000 more from Houston or the
500,000 more from New York City more New
Yorkers than live on Staten Island you
know in camps with concentration some of
them big enough to fit the same number
of people who live in Atlanta or Kansas
City or Cleveland or New Orleans now you
might not need to house all 11 million
people because some of these people
would kill themselves rather than go
back or they would resist the roundup
and would be killed humanely I'm sure
still you'd better make the taps with
concentration just a little bigger
because well sorry to be necessary just
to make the process go more smoothly and
more humanely make it illegal you know
to help were hide anybody accused of
being an undocumented American maybe
Trump would make it illegal to not turn
in any undocumented Americans you knew
of and anybody guilty of one of these
crimes would have to go into the camps
to you know the camps with concentration
but don't worry Trump intends to do it
humanely these would be humane camps
with concentration and what could
possibly go wrong in them it'll be done
humanely
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space